io ai giapponesi appoggio veramente
tutto ma questo no questo no no tutor
non questo o di modifica
no no questo è un suk a pechino hanno
non puoi non poesia è un succo alla
pesca e ma nulla ho capito moltissimi
piatti e si fanno apprezzare
che bello no questo no vieni un attimo
con la chiarezza sulla cima ragazzi se
sicuro il carroccio si fanno fare anche
le poc
che bello non ce l'ha il cibo e lo
compro dettami devo fare un surf dai
amore che sono le [ __ ] come le prendo
io e vieni qua successo
turistica allora aspetta aspetta aspetta
aspetta che c'è poco aiuto papa suo
padre ce li tieni stefano stefano tempia
mi fa paura perché mano che schifo buono
ma non prezzi calino lanci l'esca per i
pokémon c'è giuseppe che ci ha portato
in un centro commerciale dove
all'interno passa una montagna russa
gigantesca la madonna è no raga
ed entra dentro il centro commerciale
pensavo fosse più bassa però va bene
come dobbiamo andarci per forza politica
andiamo giuseppe talmente non si
sopporta più che ha deciso di uccidersi
ma poi ragazzi a parte il fatto che esce
dal centro commerciale quindi sta cosa è
già strana ma poi passa in mezzo a una
ruota panoramica ma neanche minecraft
ragazzo non si vede che entrava dentro
ed esce di la cemi chiana roberts è una
roba assurda perché c'è scritto youtube
qui dentro ci sono le cassiere siderno
in the lich king sex e dai mercati 61
youtuber telo compresa la challenge
esatto oppure semplicemente pensano che
io su versioni insetti o la pista tanto
ci giocato il calcio è la mia vita non
ho mai vinto un cazzo cioè a queste robe
mai quindi non ho neanche registrate in
tentativo però non so se ho avuto culo o
corda però
[Applauso]
ieri pomeriggio ma come praticamente
abbiamo provato a prendere la coca cola
bianca che fanno solo in gergo calcolava
pianta dunque se non placement sta roba
stato calcolato male perché io cura
sportiva mite rai ha veramente stupendo
cv giorno mai vista una roba lì credo
sia il posto più bello che io abbia mai
visto in tutta la mia vita e non sto
scherzando il tempio di legno più grosso
al mondo madonna minchia che guida
turistica sono e poi se riusciamo
entriamo ma è una mappa di overwatch può
essere se ci penso e incredibile di che
cosa sia capace l'essere umano
pensate che io una volta ho bruciato il
pianale della cucina facendomi il tema
di mente è successo che mi sono
addormentato in m c ha però fatto così
perché gli occhi ed eravamo ad osaka
come cazzo ci siamo arrivati al osaka lo
sanno solo loro che però non me lo
vogliono dire che sto seguendo la
stamattina ma non capisco anche che giri
stanno facendo
vediamo il perché fa
mettiamo dieci minuti perché paio alta
bellissimo
ecco che viene rovinata panoramica che
cazzo è lesbica no non ti sentire
osservato mentre fai la pepita voce
sciascia che sta facendo colazione
spiega tutti che cos'è quella roba lì ti
prego perché il pollo fritto alle 8 del
mattino normale buongiorno ragazza ho
dormito qua adesso vi spiego il perchè
son svegliato è praticamente ho sentito
urlare schiamazzare da fuori e mi chiami
sono cagato addosso fortissimo progetto
mi chiaro il pazzoide nano coreano di
merda lanciato un missile
e invece no poi ho scoperto che c'è una
scuola qua vicino ma che figata
ho messo questa roba che si chiama futon
per terra sul tatami ma in compenso mi è
venuta la febbre non c'è mai stata la
mia vita un viaggio iniziato così male
dal punto di vista della salute perché
solamente di uno schifo da quattro
giorni papà mi ha detto di prendere
questa cosa qua mi ha detto che non si
sa che cazzo è un sapore orribile mi ha
detto così però di prenderla perché fa
bene quindi adesso la testerò in diretta
tv challenge per cercare di berto tutto
in una volta sola ma non chiedetemi
credo
madonna che match mi sono addormentato
ieri sera alle 8 alle 8 chi cazzo torna
l 8 non ho mai dormito in tutta la mia
vita alle 8 ma io mi sono svegliato che
sono le 5 del mattino quindi ho dormito
9 ore che è tantissimo ovviamente stanno
tutti dormendo quindi non non c'è
nessuno tranne stefano che va beh lui
non dorme mai
eccolo lì giù stefano che lavora la
macchina lc allora ragazzi questo è il
bagno non so se ve l'avevo già fatto
vedere no penso di no mi ha spiegato
stefano che la doccia prima che ci sono
state due vasche enormi e la temperatura
dell'acqua è regolata da questo aggeggio
che quando premi un pulsante fa questa
cosa qui
mag e che parte che sembra un gioco a
premi
c'è il senso dal rumore che fa ma che
figata
tra l'altro ragazzi la cosa divertente è
che ci sono due vasche enormi e quella è
la sauna distaccata cela sapone questa
non ho capito il perché qua come se
avessimo un cane ha forse per stefano
my back raga immaginatevi un tipo
ubriaco che esce da questa porta c'è un
problema nasca la fascia oggi vediamo
anche alle casse più ignoranti queste
sono quelle di sasha bellissima queste
sono le mie oggi sono un poco
eterosessuale come se è comunque ragazzi
ho una teoria su come mai i giapponesi
sono così dirigenti rispetto a noi
italiani se voi guardate la misura delle
ciabatte di legno sono gigantesche
questi quando sono piccoli e la madre di
lanciare ciabatte non è che gli lancia
guai di plastica sottoprezzo grezzo di
legno in faccia che il bambino mi chiama
troppo finisce in coma quindi guarda che
bello guardate che belli i giapponesi
hanno un sacco di qualità un sacco di
qualità i giapponesi meno male che
lasciano mi ha visto fare questa cosa
niente niente stavo riprendendo il
panorama bellissimo
allo ragazzi siamo siamo papa dove cazzo
siamo siamo a sacco siamo le bancarelle
nessuno le guarda mai ma aspettano tutti
di falsi ideali certi così abbiamo
trovato un sushi col rullo e adesso
faccio una cosa che non potrei fare
scusate dovrebbe essere un pezzo del
turno dovrebbe essere fine giallo quindi
ragazzi questa in sintesi è stata la mia
seconda settimana in giappone e ora vi
dovevo tagliare i capelli prima di
partire per il giappone solo che siccome
ho ancora dieci giorni qui in giappone o
torna a casa che sembra caparezza o me
li taglio in giappone solo che tagliano
i capelli in giappone potrei finire come
sordi che non so se l'avete visto non
sta messo molto bene prima di finire il
blog ragazzi volevo far vedere questa
perla ovviamente non ho potuto
riprendere le montagne russe nel video
perché si sa che non si può portare la
videocamera sopra però ho preso la foto
che danno alla fine della trazione no
volevo farvela vedere nel video prima di
concludere la foto è la seguente sono le
giostre che mi fanno un effetto strano
non è colpa mia ragazzi ve lo giuro dai
ragazzi si può concludere che questo
primo video del giappone secondo video
del giappone
bisogna costruire fiducia ma mi piace
anche merito del comitato ufficiale zone
costiere ci vediamo proseguito da
ragazzi
[Musica]